what makes the human-animal so unique
perhaps no one explained it better than
Ernest Becker he says man has an inner
symbolic self which signifies a kind of
freedom freedom to dream the freedom to
roam in mind the freedom to imagine and
to soar and to make manifest and
engender our imaginations right yet
we're also a bounded finite being which
signifies a limit to that freedom and
[Music]
reconciling this tension has become the
central fact of human life we have
emerged from nothing we can conceive of
the infinite seemingly capable of
anything yet housed in these bounded
finite heart pumping bread
gasping ultimately decaying bodies how
to respond then to the soaring ecstasy
the exhilarating freedom of imagination
of inner life with the boundedness with
the entropy with the constraint the
existential constraint gravity entropy
and death
[Music]
as children we know not our limitations
unbounded in imagination we soar and
dream as adults we look to children in
melancholy longing for the good old days
the endless summers were the spirits
soared and the body had not yet reminded
us of our finitude
and then we hit a wall and then we get
punched in the face and then someone we
know gets sick or a Grandma and Grandpa
died and all of a sudden death comes
into awareness the limitations the
trauma of realizing the awareness of war
cavity it starts tallit our dreams the
post traumatic stress disorder that
follows the realization that we are
beings that die is something we spend
the rest of our lives trying to
transcend and trying to curtail we are
kicking and screaming and shaking
anguish anxiety and depression the
looping thoughts and ruminations that
are really just stories ultimately
rooted in the genesis in terror the
quaking anihilation of knowing oh my god
die
[Music]
and so what do we do
is there any healthy response then to
this conundrum one way is art the poet
the noble savage he knows that he is
doomed but he will leave some stunning
artistry in his wake the difference
between the artist and the neurotic is
that the neurotic is precisely the one
who cannot create he can't marshal a
response and so he chokes on his intro
versions the artist takes in the world
is overwhelmed by the world equally
sensitive to the neurotic but he
responds he takes in the data and
reworks it into an active work project
he plants his flag he carves his name on
the tree he leaves the world a little
better when he leaves it and maybe
there's a third response as well the
scientist the engineer the human
enterprise the creative capacity to make
manifest mind in the world to impregnate
the world with mind and creativity and
innovation and technology as they even
thought said in the beginning of
infinity that is what we do and we
landscape the world we build the
and the great cities superstructures
that rise from the earth directed by
human agency shaped more by mind than by
geology mind has become a geologic force
mine has become an evolutionary process
mine can trump entropy when we direct
this creative capacity to the very
substrates that houses our minds by
programming biology by hacking genetics
is we are alphabetical the way that we
are made of language your DNA is a code
our genes are software programs and
increasingly our stewardship are a
genius our capacity to reprogram our
genes away from disease way even from
aging will marshal an age of biology
where a new generation of artists will
be writing genomes with the fluency that
Blake and Byron wrote versus we will
turn biology into a canvas for our
artistry we will turn ourselves into
poetry we will not go quietly into that
good night we will rage against the
dying of the light literally not just
poetically
our capacity to imagine that Kurzweil to
create virtual models virtual realities
in our brains imagination combined with
this thing
the modest-looking thumb was sufficient
to usher in a secondary force of
evolution right see I'm keeping it
natural a force of evolution known as us
a way for the cosmos to know itself
directing with its own agency remaking
the world in its image and its likeness
and it will continue until the entire
universe is our fingertips until we
infuse consciousness our style of
consciousness into everything
[Music]
we will cognate eyes the world we will
impregnate the world with mind we will
sing the songs that were castrate the
universe
[Music]
and in the words of Alan Harrington
having invented the gods might turn into
them aspire to this my friends for
nothing else will do nothing else will
do
you